يُزعم أن المتظاهرين المؤيدين للإصلاح اخترقوا
التلفزيون الرسمي الإيراني يوم السبت لتعطيل
برنامج Nightly News الذي كان يبث
مقطعًا مع المرشد الأعلى
آية الله علي خامنئي ، نعم ، لقد
استبدلوا البث بصورة
لخامنئي مع وضع هدف على
وجهه إلى جانب صور
شابات لديهن  توفيت في إيران الشهر الماضي ،
ويأتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي تجتاح فيه احتجاجات عنيفة هذا البلد لأسابيع
بعد وفاة ماسا أميني البالغة من العمر 22 عامًا ،
وتوفيت أثناء احتجازها بعد أن
احتجزتها شرطة الآداب الحكومية
بسبب عدم ارتدائها
الحجاب بشكل صحيح على شبكة سي إن إن.  ليس هناك بشير ينضم
إلينا الآن ليس لديه أي شخص ينسب الفضل في
هذا الاختراق ،
نعم بالتأكيد رأينا الآن
مجموعة واحدة تنسب الفضل إلى هذا أه في
الرسالة الليلة الماضية كان هذا كان علي أن
أقول أن بوريس عمارة كان عرضًا رائعًا
وعلنيًا للغاية للتحدي ضد
النظام الإيراني كما أشرت
هناك هو عرض حقيقي للاحتجاج
على النظام المتشدد تلك الصورة لـ
Ay
يظهر في الله مقدمة ووسط هذا
الانقطاع اللحظي لمذيع الدولة الإيراني
خلال بثه الليلي
الذي كان من المفترض أن يكون حوالي الساعة 9 مساءً بالتوقيت المحلي
يجلس الكثيرون لمشاهدة
مذيع الدولة في ذلك الوقت تقريبًا
مع رسم لهدف
مثبت على وجهه الرسالة
هناك  انتفض وانضم إلينا بالطبع في
إشارة إلى الاحتجاجات التي
رأيناها تجري في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ولكن كما أوضحت هناك ،
كانت هناك أربع صور رئيسية في
الجزء السفلي ، وهي رسالة مؤثرة
حقًا صورة ماسا  أميني ،
المرأة البالغة من العمر 22 عامًا والتي أثارت وفاتها حقًا
شرارة هذه الحركة الاحتجاجية التي
رأيناها محتجزة من قبل
شرطة الأخلاق الإيرانية سيئة السمعة
وبالطبع ماتت في الحجز ولكن
أيضًا صور ثلاث
نساء أخريات توفين خلال الدورة.  من
هؤلاء الاحتجاج نيكا شاكرامي الحديث
النجفي وبالطبع سيرينا إسمي ثلاث
نساء جائت بالفعل لتمثيلها أيضًا
إلى جانب Masa I me  هذه الحركة
وشهدنا استمرار الوحشية
والعنف على أيدي
شرطة الأخلاق التابعة لقوات الأمن الإيرانية والسلطات الأخرى
ردًا على
عروض التحدي هذه ، لكن هذه كانت حقًا
رسالة عامة تظهر حقًا
المشاعر هناك.
البلد